Ragnarok is soon upon us specifically
God of War Ragnarok so we're taking a
look at the central figures of the game
and looking at their actual story in
Norse myth how it is similar or
different to what we've already seen in
God of War and what that all might mean
for kratos's ultimate fate and today
we're starting with a crowd favorite
despite being one of the most famous
mythological Gods known today Loki is
also one of the most misunderstood and
not just by the other Acer aka the Norse
Gods like for example did you know that
Loki in mythology isn't actually Thor's
brother yeah that was a thing that Stan
Lee came up with Loki has had numerous
depictions throughout pop culture all
shifting and playing with the Norse
mythology which fits our shape-shifting
friend quite well but let's try to find
the truth of his story so we'll focus on
Loki's history in Scandinavian myth to
discuss how he might or might not appear
in the God of War games oh and ample
spoiler warning on this one for all of
the God of War games if you know you
know with that said let's travel the
bifrost into the mythology of Loki in
real life Moki is actually one of the
last gods that historians Found Records
of he wasn't even mentioned until
centuries after the Romans encountered
the Scandinavians meaning that Loki
likely showed up in myth way later than
most of the other gods even further we
don't even know a hundred percent who
his parents are in myth his father is
the giant farbati but his mother could
be Lao Faye hence his name Loki laupeson
or null but we don't even know if Lao
Faye or null are even a seer in fact
Loki first encountered the Acer when he
met Odin while wandering the nine Realms
and the two became fast friends and even
Blood Brothers though the reasons for
which are unknown this ambiguous origin
has actually played a role in countless
iterations of Loki and pop culture one
which God of War 2018 takes it advantage
of because and huge spoiler warning here
this is your last chance we learn at the
end of the game that atreus kratos's son
is actually Loki himself the Giants
called me
Loki
what's the name your mother wanted for
you when you were born here Loki or
atreya says we'll call him is the child
of Kratos himself and laufei who Kratos
affectionately called Faye and was a
giant despite dying before the game
starts Faye raised atreus with Kratos
even giving the boy his Talon bow like
Loki and myth atreus has spent his
entire life sequestered from everyone
else never encountering a god until the
game's events but here though he's
intelligent and happy-go-lucky but takes
things seriously when he needs to
we are not men
we are more than that
the responsibility is far greater
and you must be better
to understand
say it
or you will be better
mythological Loki though by contrast is
cunning in clever but uses this skill
for trickery he brings chaotic neutral
energy to everything he does yet the
other Acer don't hate him for this
because while he can be frustrating he's
tolerated because he often helps them
for example one day for fun Loki cuts
the hair off of Sif one of the Acer
whose hair was renowned for its beauty
when Thor who was married to Sif found
out he threatened to pulverize Loki who
in Terror says that he will get the
dwarves to make Sif more hair to rectify
the damage that he did and Loki actually
followed through getting the dwarves to
make Sif more hair and they also at the
same time made a great ship called skip
bald near and a spear named gugnir Loki
who thought that this was really cool
and enjoyed hanging out with the doors
decided to pass the time by betting two
dwarves Brock and cindry his head that
they couldn't create something even
better than that ship and Spear and the
two actually took the BET as they worked
though Loki attempted to cheat by
turning into a fly and stinging their
hands neck and eyelids trying to ruin
their work yet despite this they
actually did make some excellent rings
and a hammer whose handle was too short
due to Loki's messing around with them
and they decided to name this Hammer
mjolnir yes that mjolnir Thor's famous
Hammer the doors presented these gifts
to the Acer and the Acer loved them
especially Thor who loved his new Smash
and things hammer and so Brock and
sindri were about to take Loki's head as
a prize but he pointed out that he had
promised his head and not his neck so
instead the dwarf sewed his mouth shut
which you know sounds fair all of this
trickery is at odds with where we see
atreus in Ragnarok Thor for example
seems to already have mjolnir in the
game when atreus meets him even though
it was also made by Brock and sindri a
trace in the game may be playful but is
rarely seen to be playing tricks just to
mess with people further atreus seems
was generally curious about the world
yet is accepted by his father and those
he meets even the dwarves broken
syndrome themselves who seemed to like
Loki's questions and Company unlike his
mythological counterpart
what I'm on a [ __ ] break don't hear
me screeching at you whenever you're
twiddling your short and curlies leaving
boy
no trap
oh you already soiled my solitude so you
may as well join me
conversely though Loki of myth is always
seen as the Black Sheep which is
probably why he acts out in the first
place this all comes to a head in one of
my favorite stories in Norse myth the
locus Senna in it Loki turns up drunk at
a party held by the other gods and I
mean he is sloppy drunk and he starts
bringing up everyone else's embarrassing
stories in order to mess with them like
for example he tells the goddess idoun
be silent a dune of all women I declare
the most fond of men since thou thy arms
carefully washed ditched twine round thy
brother's murderer oh yeah Loki accused
idoun of being pernicious and even
sleeping with her brother's killer it's
spicy it's spicy stuff but Loki is
rightfully angry considering that he's
often blamed for many of the Acer's
problems and is seen as a villain when
the Acer themselves are just as big a
jerks as he is I mean Thor for example
is super racist against dwarves and Odin
love to stir up War with humans just for
fun while the dynamic of 2018's God of
War differs because atreus actually
hasn't met many of the Acer yet atreus
does face a similar distance from his
own father Kratos Kratos spends much of
the game attempting to connect with
atreus but finds it difficult without
Faye his wife to help guide him
wish Mom was here to see it
[Music]
as a result this sometimes makes atreus
feel inadequate to his father's
affections in much the same way that
Loki of myth felt distanced from the
Acer yet in Norse mythology the gods are
much less affectionate than Kratos which
is saying something after Loki's drunken
tirade Odin is pissed off and calls Loki
not a real man accusing Loki of spending
time on Earth as a milk maid and having
children saying thou was eight Winters
on the earth below milk cow is a woman
and it's their bare children now that
methinks but stokens a base nature who
would have thought that Kratos would
look like the emotionally adjusted one
compared to anybody yet in Odin's
accusations he didn't just say that Loki
had children he actually said that he
bore them which brings us to another
critical aspect of Loki his gender which
will become surprisingly relevant to the
story of Ragnarok itself we tend to
think of things like gender fluidity as
a more modern Western concept today but
Loki was messing around with his gender
for years in myth for example Loki often
likes to shape-shift or even dress up in
women's clothing for fun like when he
pretends to be a bridesmaid for a
wedding in order to trick Giants yet
Loki's sex and gender are even more
fluid than that one day an unknown
Builder came to the Acer to say that
he'll build a giant wall around Asgard
that the yotinar the Giants wouldn't be
able to get through however the price is
high as the Builder wants to be paid
with the Sun the moon and Freya as his
bride the Acer agree to this over
freya's protest with the condition that
the Builder must finish the wall all by
himself within a single winter or no
payment believing that the Builder will
never actually be able to do it and
they'll get a free wall in the process
basically the Acer like to abuse the
contract employee system surprisingly
though three days before the end of
winter it looks like the Builder will
finish on time so the gods turn to Loki
to fix the situation so Loki turns
himself into an attractive female mare
in heat and bats her luscious eyes at
the Builder's stallion who breaks free
and chases down Loki ruining the
Builder's work the Builder angry reveals
that he's actually a giant and gets his
face smashed in by Thor's hammer the gig
economy am I right well all this is
happening though Loki gets his freak on
with the stallion and gets pregnant yep
Loki gets pregnant and eventually gives
birth to an eight-legged horse named
slip near who Odin then rides as his
Mount just um
just sit with that for a minute
fiction is vastly different than atreyus
and God of War who stays a young boy the
whole game yet the reason that I bring
up Loki's gender however is that it
plays a part in the story of the end of
the world Ragnarok as Loki in mythology
is also the parent of three other
children the goddess of death hell the
world Serpent jormungound and the Wolf
fenrir so yeah Loki birthed the horse a
literal snake that coils around the
world a giant wolf and the goddess of
death
Loki gets around each of these children
has a long-fated role in the Battle of
Ragnarok for example fenrir and jorming
gound help lead the Earth's destruction
with fenrir eating the ground in the sky
and Norman gound flooding the Seas upon
the land this is just a tad different in
the game given that atreus did not seem
to give birth to jormungound at least
that we know of nor the game's version
of hell but this leads us to Loki's
final fate and how the mythological Loki
might eventually tie into God of War's
portrayal Boulder in myth was one of
Odin's favorite Sons but was fated to be
killed as a sign of the coming Ragnarok
so balder's mother forced every entity
in the cosmos to swear an oath not to
harm Boulder thinking that this might
protect him from his fate but then Loki
got involved in the guise of a woman
Loki asked balder's mother if everything
had sworn an oath to which she revealed
that yes everything except from
mistletoe because how could mistletoe
harm anyone she had thought and Loki
took this as challenge accepted and
tricked the god rondir into throwing a
spear made of mistletoe at balder
rodnier agrees thinking that he couldn't
possibly hurt balder given his oath but
of course the spear goes right through
balder killing him this moment frightens
the Acer as balder's death was the sign
that Ragnarok was surely on its way way
after his death balder himself was
condemned to remain in the hands of Hell
Loki's child in her domain of death in
Anger the gods killed Loki's son narfi
and tied Loki himself up with his own
entrails in a cave above him they placed
a snake that would endlessly drip Venom
upon Loki as his wife sat at his side
with a bowl to catch it yet when the
bull begins to overflow and she pours it
out the Venom falls on Loki's face
torturing him it is here that the Asia
hoped that Loki will spend the rest of
his days but it is said that when
Ragnarok occurs and the world tree
begins to tremble Loki will break free
of his chains and along with his
children yorman gound and fenrir will
help to bring about Ragnarok with
jormungound himself fighting Thor in a
final battle Loki will lead a group of
giants to attack Asgard and will himself
be killed at the hands of Heimdall who
will also die at the trickster's hands
now some of this does and some of it
doesn't match up with atreus in God of
War 2018 atreus does shoot Boulder with
mistletoe arrows given to him by his
mother which then Freeze balder from a
curse that his mother Freya placed upon
him to make him Immortal used
to pay for the lifetime that you stole
from me Kratos then kills balder with
atreus's help this isn't the same as
Norse myth but it does rhyme with it and
bothers death as it does in mythology
does signal the coming of Ragnarok
heralding thimblewinter
foreign
so what might this mean for God of War
Ragnarok well atreus certainly has a
destiny as the paintings at the end of
the game showcase a prophecy that
foretold atreus and creators Journey
this leads the two to surmise that
atreus is actually part giant like his
mother before him which fits with Loki's
mysterious origin
she was a giant
[Music]
I'm a giant a treasan Kratos himself may
eventually face the Acer's wrath for
killing Boulder meaning that we may even
see one of them locked in Chains in a
cave during the story of the sequel and
setting them free may be a big part of
the game and while we have yet to see
Heimdall in the games if we do that may
signal atreus's ultimate fate only time
and the gods will tell
or you know playing God of War Ragnarok
so this is where we leave Loki slash
atreus for now but if you want to learn
more about Norse mythology and how it
may tie into God of War Ragnarok don't
forget to subscribe to Gamespot as we'll
have more God of War videos coming in
the next few weeks and in the meantime
check out all of our coverage on God of
War Ragnarok right here on Gamespot
we will we will be the gods we choose to
be
not those who have been
who I was
is not who you'll be